that's right which of Minecraft mobs
could I beat in a fight let's settle
this once and for all
I've always wanted to know this even
before I play Minecraft
I made this cute little template this is
obviously based of the idubbbz made a
video and he did it based on someone
else it's tearless which he made popular
I've always wanted to do them so here we
are you can download this template put
them into yourself if you want to but
this is however my choices and I beg you
to respect them now like any moral
choices it depends on the context here
okay
the context of this fight is that we're
fighting to the death all right hence
the death bars here anything lining in
here is as good as dead
we're fighting to do that for whatever
reason I don't know maybe Africa's
nothing whatever we've done to each
other we both want to murder each other
okay that's the context of this fight
it's not the kind of fight where our
shake hands all that was epic no
basically me versus chicken for example
chicken Frick my mom I want to kill this
chicken and I likewise did two dead
sheep you understand what I mean okay
I would I would even if he would freak
my mom I wouldn't fully kill him as easy
as it would be I would beat him as close
to death as possible to learn him a
lesson what the hell is this video I
don't see myself losing against a
chicken I think my chances are pretty
strong I'm bigger I'm stronger I don't
have a beak but I could probably
simulate one pretty well who should we
do next the slime yes this is a good one
the Siamese very big and very slimy but
it seems from my experience that you
should keep punching it it will go down
there's a big area it's got a large
hitbox so I could just keep punching it
would be okay I would absolutely kill
the slime the problem is however with
the tiny slime because their god them
adorable there's no way I could kill the
tiny slime
I'm gonna leave them in the middle it's
kind of like a slime in Minecraft it
doesn't do any damage to it they can
just keep attacking me I don't care it
can be in the middle the gas in
Minecraft would 100% kill me the gas
however will fit perfectly in the pool
of I would run in fear so well that I
would somehow manage to escape I feel
pretty confident that I would be able to
escape a gas so he doesn't qualify so
far I'm winning now
the Salman in Minecraft is a tough one
obviously if it's in water it's a
different story it's gonna be pretty
difficult he has that extra aqua buff
but I would still definitely snap its
neck I eat fish I'm a pescetarian sorry
Salman now the card however is very
different I don't think I could kill a
card I think the card would definitely
kill me just kidding
I'd kill it a little less than the
Salman the skeleton arrow guy it he's
got infinite arrows okay how am I
supposed to be the guy with a freaking
weapon yeah I'm pretty sure they would
kill me probably at some point bleed to
death I gotta be honest here I know I
know everyone looks up to me and thinks
that I am this indestructible being
that's perfect in every single way and
oh my god so beautiful
the skeleton in Minecraft will kick my
ass I'm not gonna lie next we have the
bat in Minecraft absolutely destroy it I
wish there was another bar actually I'll
make another bar he gets a special
little category I call it I kill them so
hard they are removed from the game why
they bother having the bat in Minecraft
I don't know it's gone I'm sorry if you
like the bat in Minecraft I'm sorry
alright making your progress the horrors
in Minecraft if it is a tough one
realistically would I be able to kill a
horse with my bare hands probably not
realistically would the horse be able to
kill me if they really wanted to
probably yes however we have another
category is I would rather die than to
take the fight if it's my own pet of
course you're again there he belongs but
I'll still put him here for the sake of
it dolphin it's a tricky one again it's
like the water element a dolphin on land
yeah he'll win
dolphin on the water however it's a
little trickier I'm just gonna go ahead
and say it's a dolphin on land so I
would have to kill it it would be
tougher though but yeah it will die they
will die I can imagine I would be able
to kill dolphins aren't as smart as they
think they are everyone is like Oh
dolphins so smart so epic not they're
not smart there's no new ones in this
it's just me would I kill them or not
okay
the llama it's one of those things where
I probably think I could kill it cuz I
don't care it's it's not a horse I can't
have it as a pet I would definitely try
it would be a good fight but the fact
that they spit I think would freak me
out so much
they would probably end up winning I
don't like when people spit at me if you
ever come in a fight with me if you just
spit I don't know I shouldn't reveal my
secret never mind just ignore all that
just don't spit out of me okay
I don't want your germs which one should
I do next so many choices so little time
ah yes the parrot if it's IKEA bird I
would put him in a category of I would
rather die than to take the fight
however I don't think I care but could
take me on I'm sorry I don't think he
could kill me
so I would probably have to immobilize
him now if it's a normal parrot I would
100% snap its neck so I would put it
here
the shulker box is a weird one they make
these fart noises I don't see that that
could be a threat actually now think
about it I also see myself getting my
thumb is stuck in that box thing and
that would hurt a lot but I feel like if
that happens that would channel my anger
so much that I would actually manage to
pry the whole thing open and just stuff
the whole little shelter thing let me
get a bigger look at it be able to stuff
that old thing in my aunt in my family
in my face so I would definitely kill it
no wait it's over here yeah yeah so far
it's pretty clear that I'm the superior
being here I've deliberately not picked
up any of the hard
I mean it's the same it's the same as
IKEA bird they definitely belong here I
would rather die than to take the fight
donkey are like horses but less superior
they kind of go with a llama but they're
less strong and a llama to be honest
because they don't spit just don't spit
at me okay I don't like it why would
people do that polar bear obvious one
they would kill me it's a freaking bear
same word panda while we're at it they
would kill me okay let's be honest
however baby polar bear it's gonna have
to go I'm a nice person I'm not gonna
kill a freaking baby I will immobilize
it to make them understand that I'm the
better man I wouldn't do too much though
just a little bit this bar is basically
actually shulker will die I'll kill the
shocker this bar is basically
immobilized yeah that makes sense
I like that I'll immobilize them sheep
immobilized
if it's a life and death scenario I know
people are gonna judge me it's a life
and death scenario I hope you understand
that villager I would probably have to
immobilize as well so I could put them
in my Frick shame burr basically village
or zombie obviously I have to kill but
then again they're probably stronger
than a villager man there's so many
choices and scenarios I never thought I
would ever have I think they have the
advantage because zombies are annoying
and no one likes them because zombies
are like this never-ending source they
just don't stop they just don't stop I
would run out of stamina
zombies have infinite stamina everyone
knows that the pufferfish is so cute how
could I kill this it's a frickin box
dude would I rather die than to take the
fight of a pufferfish the question is
more would I kill this thing and I think
the answer unfortunately sorry Marcia
she loves puffer fishes the answer is
that I would probably try to immobilize
it but I would I'm probably so strong
that in the process I would I would let
it live it lives ok puffer fish lives
everyone that's great what else do we
have
there's so many ok wither skeleton
obviously they have a weapon what am I
gonna go hey we're definitely finally
and they will definitely kill me not
gonna even sugarcoat it same it
villagers they have a weapon although I
have a feeling I could probably steal
the weapon so it's less likely that they
would win if I steal the weapon out
chiapas cubic little balls off I would
do it and make him eat him that which
wouldn't kill him I think that gives me
an even more advantage now that would be
a fair fight which obviously have
advantage they have potions they have
all these weird things I don't know what
the witch do exactly however I'm
terrified of witches growing up in
Sweden next to a forest and washing the
which movie has scarred me for life
Blair Witch Project it's not even scary
but in my head it's scary I hate them
however you might think that's a
weakness but I feel like that would
always built up anxiety that I have
years and years I've been walking home
from my friends and through the forest I
will channel all that and murder the
witch it's not murder its self-defense
just to be clear it's not murder all
right but she will die stone golem uhh
I couldn't kill a stone golem come on
however I could probably convince sone
Golan with my charm and sexual being and
since he is one as well to calm down a
bit which will probably leave me
immobilized oh yeah these what are these
again it's like an ender
termite or something why are they in the
game they only confuse me it's like a
10% chance that they appear if you throw
an ender pearl they 100% belong and I
would kick their ass and and I kill them
so hard they are removed from the game
you are welcome everyone applause to me
you're welcome
uh who else do we have is there anyone
else I want to kill that bad no I don't
think so not yet at least the wither
skeleton I feel like belongs and I would
run in fear so well that I would manage
to escape I know this is kind of a
cop-out but it's the truth do you want
me to not be honest now you'd think
villagers same as skeleton because they
have they have their weapon however they
recharge a lot slower and they don't
have infinite arrows I would say this is
a pretty fair fight I could probably
take them on zombie piggie however would
kill me
real piggy I would absolutely immobilize
it it's the most pointless video of all
time and her dragon I think would I
think I'm gonna have to just accept that
ender dragon will kill me this giant
what are they called Ravagers I think
I'll just have to accept that they will
kill me I think that's fair if I freaked
his mom I think I probably deserved to
die anyway I probably want to die anyway
there's very little where in this area I
wonder why that is
spider would probably kill me they're
giant they're gross I wouldn't even want
to fight them although they are so gross
and so nasty that I would probably
persevere and I would probably try my
best to kick the rats actually God
spiders are gross I hate spiders
see that's the thing I think I think if
I go so far as to win
I would probably kill it I would
definitely make sure it dies you know
what III you know what I'm gonna do it
I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do it I'm
doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it
that's right so it kills so hard they
are removed from the game it had to be
done gamers I don't like spiders knotch
do something call up Microsoft I don't
know I'm sure you have some
points it's a cow stronger than a llama
no I was really mad at a cow would I be
able to kill it cows are big men you
could tip them over though I've done
that I mean I haven't done that you can
tip cows over and then they're
completely destroyed and was it well
stirred down I could probably get a lot
of good punches in I feel like I could
go for the kidneys I go for a specific
organ I could probably break him so I'm
gonna put him here on the edge I don't
really I don't really want to kill all
immobilize him he'll have to get a liver
transplant or something like that but
he'll live baby zombie I would
definitely kill and yeah that's right
that's right I kill them so hard they
are removed from the game you are
welcome
the real zombie however I would
immobilize because I want them to live
with the sadness and sorrow over knowing
that I killed their child snowman
obviously belongs in there I would I
would not want to hurt them territory I
guess that that's what this is cat
obviously belongs in no wait
cat OH yeah I'll kill a cat I don't know
I'm just kidding I'm kidding I would
immobilize a cat I would definitely I
know you probably have pets and maybe
you have a cat but listen if a cat comes
at you it's super dangerous you're gonna
have to immobilize that kitty vex do you
remember these
I'll show it good you probably can't see
these these guys I feel like they would
have a good chance against me they're so
small and so fast and they've actually
killed me a lot of times in Minecraft
however I will of course kill it and I
would kill it so hard is removed from
the game
does anyone want these in the game no
one wants these in the game Mojang kill
it until it's gone those phantom beings
god I hate them every time I'm trying to
do a montage yeah I'll kill them so hard
they removed from the game I'll break
his wings now actually I won't do that
yeah I like that it will break in his
wings and like properly torture him like
he tortures me every time dog of course
easy I would rather die than take the
fight no way I'll let him absolutely
belongs here Hedgehog let me show it
because it's so tiny the hedgehog will
definitely I'll stomp on it even if it
hurts my feet the pain will get meaning
knowing that it's gone and I would also
add these to kill so hard they
are gone from the game because I don't
understand what their purpose is and I
don't like them
this isn't growing in John rly I think I
should change these okay that looks
awful I like it
guardians oh god I hate these so much I
would murder them god damn I hate them
the magma flying fire shooting thing
would probably kill me they can shoot
fire come on Vindicator things I would
probably uh I would probably kick same
as villager yeah probably a little bit
more than Vindicator though the giant
fire magma thing killing although it's
it hot like the nether cuz that would
hurt my knuckles it would be harder to
kill than a slime wouldn't it plus they
also have fire resistance it's got to be
worth something slime doesn't have it I
would probably have to put it here no it
has to die nevermind zombie pigmen
riding a chicken is probably as even as
any fight could ever be I think that's
probably my strings exactly if this was
the middle point
yeah we're equally strong basically it's
what I'm saying this makes the baby
slime a bit confusing I think you should
just put it here he's probably my
perfect match in a fight a chicken baby
pig man with the golden sword is
probably a strength 'full as I am turtle
I would not kill baby turtle wish I have
here for no reason whatsoever I would
obviously no no no wait it's here yeah
baby turtle gets to live baby pig zombie
thing I would definitely kill squid oh
god I feel like a squid would kick my
ass I know that sounds weird but just
don't ask all right I don't like squids
bunny goes in here obviously I would
immobilize him one swing one Swedish
Viking swing
I would probably break his legs so he
can't jump anymore or something like
that just so he remembers not to go at
me again I don't want to have some sort
of situation I'm chilling with Myers and
then a bunny starts attacking me again
because of what I did five years ago the
likes will have to go and their men
would probably kick my ass come on they
can teleport they're scary and I don't
know if they would kill me though
they're probably a teleport away
herobrine
what is this the frak is this
yeah I'll kick his ass I don't know
never seen that in
all right so there you have it folks
yeah I'm pretty pleased with this I
think it makes sense let me know what
you guys think we'd love to hear your
feedback do you agree or disagree I'll
leave a link if you want to try this out
as well you can post it on Twitter
hashtag minecraft mob fight yeah that's
it so here we have I would rather die
than to take the fight I think that's
fair that's fair
we're a prick imple that didn't grow
more actually and that's interesting I I
would expect that to get a couple more
and then of course we have killed so
hard they're removed from the game
you are welcome everyone okay I'm Matt
but with this it's much like if you
enjoyed thanks for all the love and
support on yesterday's video I worked
really hard on it so I'm glad you guys
liked it so now I will shamefully plug
my March instead thank you very much see
you guys next time bye bye stop you
haven't bought the pity pie figurine
limited time only $29.99 and that's a
great price
[Music]